well let's talk uh now about the cost of
living crisis that really has been uh at
the sort of center of our interviews
this morning uh one thing that really
struck me over the summer is the
disconnect between some of the political
debate in westminster and what people
are experiencing in their own lives
across the united kingdom and whether
that's what's happening in your local
school or hospital or trying to work out
on earth your wages are going to cover
your energy and food bills you know it
seems to me more important than ever to
hear some of those voices and to put
those real life experiences to the
people who have believers to do
something about it our political guests
well there's only one place to start
this week energy bills we've been
looking at the impact on small business
who of course aren't protected by the
price cap now a typical pub was paying
about 15 and a half thousand pounds on
energy that's expected to rise to just
under 50 000 pounds according to the
british beer and pub association up more
than 200
now the industry employs some 940 000
people and there are around 47 000 pubs
in the united kingdom
so we can talk now to the owner of a pub
to find out what is going on this
morning we're going to take you to
thornton laddale a very picturesque
village in north yorkshire at the center
of that village is the buck inn we can
talk to its owner
abby marshall now thank you so much for
being on the program
this morning abby
just talk with us through first how much
of your energy bill's gone up
uh so just to put into context uh we
bought the pub in september 21 so
11 12 months ago
we are not connected to maine's gas here
so we run off an lpg tank
uh the when we filled the tank when we
moved in september 21 uh to when we
filled the tank four weeks ago that had
gone up 285 percent
we're due to get our new electricity
bill um which we are predicting uh is
due to coming on monday which will be
300
so if you add that all together i'm
predicting sophie my utility should go
from about 22 000 to about 58 000
wow so that really is you know a big
rise you must be hit by food price
inflation as well yeah and i think the
problem is as well so whilst um
obviously everybody's talking about
utilities at the moment and it is
extremely important for the past six
months you know hospitality and all
small businesses we've been seeing
direct cost of doing business
escalating uh beyond what we've ever
seen before and the problem is you know
when you're running a small business or
any business and you're trying to
control your costs and every single
direct cost of your business is
escalating at a point that you have no
control over it
uh it's very worrying cost of food cost
of beer
utilities uh v80 for example v80 was 5
that's gone to 20 so we've just paid our
first v8 bill at 20
which was
excruciatingly painful
business rates as well you know they're
50 at the moment um but again they're
due to go up to 100 so what you're
looking at is uh you know you're
forecasting and you're looking at your p
l and
and every single line on your p l is is
just growing and it's not stopping you
know it's just completely escalating and
then there comes a point where you um
you can't streamline your business you
can't look at your business and say how
do we deal with these costs
because every single one of those costs
really is out of your control
it's really you know we spoke about your
the increased your energy bills you know
when you told my producer that fish and
chips has had to go up from 12 19 95 to
17.95 yes
absolutely just a silly example so for
you know 1295 september 21 1795 now what
we started doing as well is we started
moving away from menus permanent menus
just because uh the price fluctuation on
on product and inventory is so up and
down at the moment that what
if we were to physically print a menu i
can guarantee within three to four weeks
a lot of those prices will be obsolete
um so we've gone to specials boards uh
where we can change the you know change
the pricing week by week or every couple
of weeks the chefs are continuously
looking at price point um
and i think the scary thing is how
quickly it changes uh that's definitely
something that's that sort of really hit
home for me is the speed in which it
changes is the fact that you try and put
it together a set of figures and within
a couple of weeks those those aren't
correct uh you're behind
it's really uh you know it is a bit of
an eye to be honest you know talking to
you this morning and just getting the
kind of real world example about what
rising inflation actually means it's one
of those words you kind of chuck around
and in political interviews and you
don't really think about the real world
examples in terms of you know fish and
chips or a pint at your apartment yeah
of course all the people that rely on
those businesses as well uh liz trusts
uh we believe or maybe russia sunaka are
going to be setting out their plan to
deal with the cost of living in energy
in the coming week
what do you need what if you know if the
next prime minister was watching this
now what do you need them to do
i think i think there's a few things
sophie well from my perspective and
obviously i can't speak for all smes and
small businesses but i think obviously
vat jumping from 5 to 20 has been a huge
a huge issue for us i'd like to see a a
cutting vat
i'd like to say see a holiday on
business rates which you know i mean
we've been talking about business rates
for a decade it's it's um
it's a system that doesn't work it's not
representative of the market as it is
now so i think that whole system he's
looking at um and i think there needs to
be a cap on utilities you know
ultimately we're an employer um just an
example we're in a very small village
but if we were to go
you'd be looking at 15 to 17 people
without jobs so when you start looking
at that's just one small pub in in a
small village uh the scale of of the
problem uh times that by you know 30 000
pubs and that's just hospitality never
mind your bakeries and your cafes and
your other small businesses um so v80
business rates holiday and a cap and
utilities would be a start but then i
think we've got to think about how do we
future-proof our businesses moving
forward um we unfortunately are very we
use a lot of energy we have fridges we
have ovens we have cooling systems we
have sellers uh there's got to be some
sort of long-term um idea of how we move
forward as a sector and what we get you
know are we gonna are they gonna enable
us to install green energy are we gonna
be able to install solar something just
to future-proof ourselves from this
happening again
thank you uh so much it's been really
interesting to talk to you this morning
abby uh and you know good luck in the
months ahead let's hope there's
something for you thank you sophie